well welcome to this windowless room on
this beautiful day it's a pleasure to
see you all here my name is Beverly gage
and I am a professor in the history
department here I am NOT Ian Shapiro who
is the head of the Macmillan Center and
the Henry are Luce director here Ian
could not be here today because of
teaching duties and he asked me to
welcome you all here to the Macmillan
Center for this important talk we are
delighted to host ambassador Nicholas
burns as this year's George Herbert
Walker jr. lecture in International
Studies the Honorable George Herbert
Walker the third Yale College class of
1953 and former ambassador to the
Republic of Hungary established this
lecture series in 1986 in memory of his
father who was another distinguished
Yale graduate the class of 1927 we are
very fortunate to have family members
and friends of the Walker family with us
today the Walker lecture is a signature
series presented by the Macmillan Center
and has featured many many prominent
lecturers including Madeleine Albright
Richard Holbrooke and a long list of
others so you are in good company
ambassador burns ambassador burns is the
Roy and Barbara Goodman family professor
of the practice of diplomacy and
international relations at the Harvard
Kennedy School of Government
he is also faculty director of the
future of diplomacy project and the
faculty chair of the programs in the
Middle East and South Asia and he's
director of the Aspen Strategy Group as
well as a senior counselor at the Cohen
group and I may have left off a few
pieces of the many many things that you
do from 2014 to 2016 he was a member of
Secretary of State John Kerry's foreign
affairs policy board at the u.s.
Department of State for those of you in
the audience who are Yale students I
should note that John Kerry will also be
on on campus this coming fall ambassador
burns served in the US Foreign Service
for 27 years until his retirement in
April of 2008 he was Undersecretary of
State for political affairs from 2005 to
2008 prior to that he was ambassador to
NATO ambassador to Greece and State
Department spokesman he has worked on
the National Security Council staff
where he was senior director for Russia
Ukraine and Eurasian affairs and special
assistant to President Clinton and
before that director for Soviet affairs
for President George HW Bush he has
covered as you can see just about every
place in the world and every position
within the State Department and academia
and it is an honor to have him here
today he is also as you can see a man of
great ambition and has taken on the
daunting challenge of telling us all
about the Trump administration's global
foreign policy challenges and he's going
to solve them all for us here today so
please join me in welcoming dr. Berg
well professor gage thank you very much
that's a tall order to decipher Donald
Trump and explain everything in one
short lecture but thank you very much
for the invitation thank you for the
very generous introduction good
afternoon everyone it's a pleasure to be
here here at Yale I took the train from
Boston it's a beautiful day this is a
great campus and I just reminded of that
every time I come here what a beautiful
historic campus this is what a great
University this is no punch lines here
no Yale jokes are coming I truly and
sincerely mean this and thanks to
professor gage we just had a short talk
about her research she's working on a
book about J Edgar Hoover which I'm now
anxious to read having heard a little
bit about that book and that great
figure and controversial figure in some
ways in American history I'm also very
honored and I know they're members of
the Walker family here to give the
george herbert walker jr. memorial
lecture I served with his son ambassador
Walker when he was ambassador to Hungary
I was US ambassador to NATO during
President George HW Bush's first term in
office and I certainly am very proud to
have served both President George W Bush
but also President George HW Bush George
President George Herbert Walker Bush who
was one of my heroes and I arrived at
the NSC staff at the White House in the
spring of 1990 just before one of his
summit meetings with President Mikhail
Gorbachev I was brought over by a young
Stanford professor on the NSC staff by
the name of Condoleezza Rice I became
her deputy and we were the two-person
Soviet team for President George HW Bush
what a great president he was and just
looked back in his record he helped to
achieve the peaceful the Democratic
peace in Europe at the end of the Cold
War the end of the Cold War without a
shot being fired
masterful diplomacy with Boris Yeltsin
Mikhail Gorbachev Helmut Kohl he and
secretary Jim Baker who was a great
Secretary of State were the primary
movers to unify Germany after the fall
of the Berlin Wall the Oh
the wall really in 1990 when Germany was
unified they led the big coalition
against Saddam Hussein but then
President George HW Bush had the good
sense to be restrained and what he did
he accomplished his mission but didn't
try to occupy Baghdad great president
very honored to be here with members of
the Walker family and the Bush family
and to think of the what the Bush's had
done in the walkers for America in
public service I know that George
Herbert Walker jr. graduate of Yale was
very civic-minded very much involved at
Yale in your Alumni Association on
behalf of baseball and such as my esteem
for the Walker family but I even forgive
them for helping to found the New York
Mets because the mess broke my heart
when they defeated my beloved Boston Red
Sox in the 1986 World Series but I
forgive the walkers officially for that
today and thank you to all the members
who are here I real also realize I'm
behind enemy lines of sorts because I'm
an emissary of the People's Republic of
Cambridge Massachusetts here in New
Haven
there's the Harvard Yale thing that goes
on but we're really sister institutions
we had great respect for Yale at Harvard
I was just at the Yale Harvard hockey
game we got the better of you there the
final game but you got the better of us
in Cambridge and football it was a great
game this past autumn so two great
institutions and I'm very pleased to be
here on behalf of one speaking to all of
you about one of your graduates my task
is is difficult is to try to explain and
decipher the foreign policy challenges
that President Trump has inherited we
have very little to go on
100 plus days hundred and three or four
days of his time in office very early in
this time of office but I want to start
by saying two things the first is I
think America is in good shape as a
global power I don't share these the
conventional thought it's in some of our
academic circles that somehow the United
States has fallen from grace somehow
China is going to overtake us in the
next month or two as the leading global
power
I think we can be optimistic about the
United States we still have a leading
global economy two larges by any minute
by GDP it's certainly the most important
in terms of innovation and if you look
at the 21st century strengths of any
global economy if you think of our
strengths in nanotechnology
biotechnology Boston's become one of the
hubs of biotechnology globally which
we're very proud of in the emerging
digital age our strengths in Austin
Texas Research Triangle North Carolina
here in New Haven Silicon Valley Boston
were the world leader economically we
should be the world leader in the next
digital age that is coming and we should
have some we should take some hope from
that we certainly militarily are still
the strongest country in the world file
long mile and whatever you think of our
interventions in Iraq and Afghanistan in
the last decade and I supported them
obviously as a member of the George W
Bush administration I support them at
the time our American military acquitted
itself honorably effectively they showed
us I thought grit and determination they
achieved a lot and they're still doing
that they're still out there they're
back in Iraq they're in Syria they're
fighting a series of terrorist movements
really from the Horn of Africa all the
way over to the west coast of Africa in
Mauritania and modeling can be proud of
our military and our military lead in
terms of aggregate power we spend more
on our military about six hundred and
fifty billion dollars a year by the way
of taxpayers money then the next ten
countries combined and then I think of
our diplomatic power our political power
our ability to persuade our influence in
the world we're not always the most
popular country I served as a diplomat
in five different countries and West
Africa the Middle East and Europe I it's
on the receiving end of my fair share of
anti-americanism
but they still call us when the chips
are down whether it's the Indians in
Pakistan he's arguing over Kashmir or
the Israelis and Palestinians still
calling now Jared Kushner to be the
intermediary I knew the person in the
son-in-law president
Trump who's been designated to be the
emissary to those two countries China
and Taiwan the United States had
enormous political influence and my
colleague at Joe Nye is this great
professor at Harvard who's now just
become an emeritus professor after 50
odd years teaching at our at our
university he could eat coined the term
soft power that every country in the
world has it Mexico is a lot of soft
power the United States has a lot of
soft power in our case it's probably a
combination of Disneyworld
Silicon Valley our Constitution is
amended Martin Luther King and the
tradition of civil disobedience redeem
the promise of America 100 years after
the Civil War and you go overseas this
is what people talk about when they
admire the United States we have a lot
of that so I would just begin at a
hopeful note because it is so
fashionable to say that somehow our best
days are over and riilu said this is the
American Century I wouldn't be so
arrogant or so bold to say that we're
going to own the 21st century several
countries will be powerful will be I
think Prima Center Paris the most
powerful country I would think the next
three or four decades into the future so
we should take heart from that and
president Trump does not inherit a
government or a country that's failing
and one of the things that bothered me
and I'll be an equal-opportunity critic
of our 2016 campaign and I'll tell you
to be fully transparent I was working
for Secretary Clinton for 16 months in
the campaign I hope she would win I was
bitterly disappointed when she lost but
it bothered me that when from the left
and three of my daughters and most of my
students supported Bernie Sanders but
Bernie Sanders described in America that
was failing and then from the right or
were from wherever he is on a given day
on the political spectrum president
Trump candidate Trump also said you know
we had is he decried our trade
agreements he denigrated our alliances
he described a country and government
that was failing and that's not real
that's not the reality that I know from
my time in government we are highly
imperfect but we're still a great
with great values a distinguished
tradition in global affairs
we've made our fair share of mistakes in
the last 15 or 20 years particularly in
our reaction to 9/11 I think that's
clear but we still have a lot to offer
from the world I hope that President
Trump
values that and understands it as he
goes forward to represent us on the
global stage I want to start there
that's the first thought but the second
thought is that this is a really
complicated time in global history and
if we could just peer into the inbox at
President Trump and the on his Oval
Office desk I would say but I'm I've got
to be a little bit careful have an
eminent historian sitting in the front
row I would say that this might be the
most complex set of challenges
internationally that any American
president has faced since Franklin
Delano Roosevelt during the Second World
War might be I didn't say by the way
just three caveats with historians
present I did not say it's the most
fateful time in American history it's
not the Revolution was the most faithful
time it had to be the existential moment
will we succeed or fail it's not the
most dangerous time and that was clearly
the South's rebellion against the Union
in April 1860 and the battle over
slavery and the preservation of the
Union that Lincoln brilliantly
brilliantly preserved for us one for us
and in a interesting sort of way we
think of the United States as B homuth
this colossal power globally we are in
many ways but between 1942 and 1945 with
16 million men and women in uniform
millions of them serving in the European
Middle Eastern Pacific Theaters as we
fought the forces of fascism in that
epic struggle so we've seen much more
difficult times those three and many
others than we're facing right now but I
still maintain this is a highly complex
time how would we how would I describe
that just look into the inbox of
President Obama our now president Truong
in a lot of ways what we're facing now
are these big transnational problems
that
and I should have recognized him at the
very beginning but you know I was so
fortunate to have him here the former
President of Mexico that you faced and
your colleagues faced and our world
leaders still face these are the
problems that unite seven and a half
billion people in 195 nation-states
climate change trafficking of women and
children which is a big problem
organized trafficking of human beings
around the world criminal cartels and
drug cartels we know a lot about that in
North America we fight them the threat
of pandemics if we think of SARS and
Ebola and Zika and now the cyber world
that is dominating the discussion of
international politics cyber espionage
cybercrime we're organized criminal
networks are reaching into our iPhones
and laptops and company databases to try
to suck out our personal information our
private banking information or
intellectual property and the
possibility the next big war if God
forbid there is going to be a next big
war in the nuclear age but the next big
superpower conflict if it ever did start
it would be catastrophic it would be
insane to launch it but it would start
in cyberspace one country would try to
knock out and blind knock out the other
country satellites and blind it in the
first moments of a war this is an
incredibly complex environment and all
these transnational issues and there are
about 30 or 40 others that I think if we
went around the room we could
collectively just recall off the top of
our heads their new and international
politics in a way they dominate
international politics it means that no
country can think of itself as the
proverbial island that no country can
think that they can stand away from
these problems or as 19th and 18th
century Americans might have thought the
Atlantic and Pacific will protect us we
don't really need to emulate the great
powers we can resist international
politics we can stand aside and watch
others no longer true in this age of
transnational problems in globalization
the reason I mentioned those as I've
served President Obama
and president the two President Bush's
and President Clinton have worked for
three of them a lot of their time in the
post Cold War era of all the time of our
presidents and the presidents of Mexico
and the president of China and the Prime
Minister of Great Britain are spent
forming coalition's on each of these
issues there's a climate change
coalition the most modern rendition was
organized by Xi Jinping and Barack Obama
in 2014 they came together as a two
largest carbon emitters they led the
drive towards the Paris agreement that
great agreement that we must preserve
and not walk away from and on any of
these other issues the coalition's would
look a little bit different the
countries leading it would be different
we have North American coalition's
because of the symbiotic relationship
the virtuous positive symbiotic
relationship that the United States
enjoys with Mexico and Canada and our
presidents and prime ministers need to
keep these coalition's running every day
this is how 7.5 billion human beings
survive in the world it's how we take on
the big challenges is how we understand
that we're all kind of adrift on a boat
together and we're going to sink or swim
together and that's a very important
point that I'm not sure the Trump
administration has internalized but it's
how the presidency has run these days is
how George HW Bush ran his time as
presidents well as George W Bush and
Bill Clinton so these transnational
problems are really key to the future
our students get it our students at Yale
and Harvard have grown up in a world
where this is just second nature we
don't deny the science we are
empiricists we're sons and daughters of
the Enlightenment we don't deny science
we try to Beach we understand we're
challenged by it and we understand we
have to react to it and we have to
devise human solutions to human problems
and that's what these net transnational
problems represent and that's the big
job of our president as global leader
because of the dominant role we play
internationally along with that I think
if you you know if you gave truth Sarah
to the last four or five occupants to
the Oval Office and said okay you tell
us what the three or four largest
challenges are beyond the transnational
issues that I talked about I think they
pretty much agree in what it is what
they are excuse me a weakening Europe a
turbulent violent Middle East and a big
generational challenge ahead to keep the
peace with China but not be dominated by
China I think if you ask the two
President Bush's and President Clinton
and President Obama and now President
Trump even at day 100 and whatever it is
three or four what are you really
worried about and what are the long-term
global trend lines that you have to be
working at day-to-day they'd say of all
the issues those are probably the big
three let me say a word about each of
them and then I'll say a word about the
Trump administration and then we'll go
to a conversation with you I'm looking
forward to that I want to start with
Europe because there's another
conventional wisdom that I certainly
have experienced in academia but also as
a diplomat and that is the future as a
is Asia
for the United States and I do agree
with President Obama's big thought at
some point we need to pivot our
strategic attention priority attention
not exclusive attention to Asia but for
the time being let me give you three
data points to illustrate how important
Europe is to the United States europe's
our largest trade partner not China not
India not Japan Europe's the largest
investor into the American economy into
our private sector into our
infrastructure Europeans capitalized
more of that than anybody else around
the world and Europe of course is the
largest contains the largest number of
American allies in the world I was the
US ambassador to NATO between just
before 9/11 and 2005 and those 28
members of NATO who are you which are
European Canada is also an ally of the
United States they're the backbone of
the American alliance system globally so
Europe is consequential for us and it's
going through I think the greatest
crisis right now that they've had since
the end of the Cold War with the fall of
communism
the opening of the Berlin Wall the
collapse of the Warsaw Pact the collapse
of the Soviets 25 years ago that's the
presidency of Ronald Reagan and George
HW Bush Europe is in trouble I don't
think that I'm sure that the Europeans
are going to survive
NATO is going to survive I think the EU
will as well but for this American
president President Trump they're going
to need his leadership his friendship
they're gonna need the help in support
of the United States think about breaks
it prime minister to resume has started
the clock it's now 23 months until the
end of Britain's 50-year involvement
with the European Union this is going to
be a consequential event for the
Europeans and for us because Britain is
the second largest economy after Germany
it's the strongest military it's by far
the most globally oriented of all the EU
countries because of the tradition going
back to the Empire but in more in modern
times the Commonwealth I found as a
diplomat when we needed help on Japan or
in sub-saharan Africa or advice about
what to do with the Indians and
Pakistanis and the latest feuds we were
trying to broker the British had a
better sense of things because of that
heritage and because of their active
diplomacy in the 21st century they're
going to be out and that means that the
United States will have to rebuild a
channel to Europe really straight to
Berlin because of Germany's incredible
importance extraordinary importance
angular Merkel being the dominant leader
on the continent but Britain's departure
will change the EU it might make the EU
more insular it might even change the
United Kingdom itself the United Kingdom
was put together in the act of Union of
1707 Nicola Sturgeon of the Scottish
National Party has said that when
Britain leaves she's going to campaign
for a second referendum I don't know the
public opinion polls don't show it
passing now because of the depressed
price of oil North Sea oil but if
Scotland were to leave and then my
grandparents ancestral homeland Ireland
now they're talking about a replay of
the Irish question of a hundred years
ago of 1916-17 of a united Ireland
perhaps
emerging out of the ashes of Britain
leaving the European Union so in ten
years time is it probable that we'll be
looking at the United Kingdom of England
and Wales with Scotland and Ireland
apart not probable but possible that's
going to be a big change the United
States and there's so much else
happening in Europe the extraordinary
human Exodus in the autumn of 2015 of
1.5 million refugees from Syria Iraq
Afghanistan fleeing to Europe because
Europe at least the western part of
Europe
not the eastern part opened its doors
led by a Lutheran pastor's daughter who
felt that her country had it was a
historical moment to show the soul of
its country her country Germany Angela
Merkel but also an ethical obligation to
help people in this mass exodus she did
she paid for it politically I still
think she has a fairly good chance her
party of being returned to power and
September 24th we'll see but this is a
big moment for the Europeans because it
split them in half the East Europeans
one by one the Slovak the Czechs the
poles the Hungarians the Bulgarians the
Romanians the Bosnians the Serbs the
Albanians the Montenegrins the
Macedonians said no they closed their
doors to the refugees because these are
largely Muslim refugees and these East
European countries resolutely Christian
or Orthodox Christian Catholic or
Orthodox Christian I should say the West
Europeans open their doors and they had
problems assimilating all these people
the French even after the two vicious
terrorist attacks in Paris doubled the
number of refugees coming into France
double them because they felt this was
the right thing to do but this has been
a big problem for the Europeans which
they and you're seeing that in the third
big issue that they're facing after
breaks it and the arrival of so many
refugees and that's the rise of
right-wing populism these right-wing
populist are running on anti-immigrant
anti-refugee anti-muslim sentiment they
are appealing to a sense of nationalism
which they equate with white Christian
nationalism and that's why I alternative
for Deutschland it's not going to win
the elections in September has become a
leading political party it will get into
the Bundestag that's why GERD builders
is still the number one ranked
politician although fortunately he did
not win his part in the Dutch elections
it's why marine lepen has a shot this
Sunday May 7th in the second round of
the French presidential elections I
think it's probable that Emmanuel macron
is going to win if you look at the data
coming out of the first round but as at
least a chance that in one of the great
democratic countries of the world an
anti-democratic right-wing I would say
racist politician could lead the French
people into the future and this problems
not going to disappear this problem of
populism we're experiencing a variation
of it in our own country it's not going
to disappear in Europe their politics is
being roiled by it and if that weren't
enough Vladimir Putin is reading Europe
not the return to the complete
ideological physical separation of to
Europe's and the Cold War but if I had
brought my map I should have he invaded
Georgia in August 2008 and is divided
into three parts at the south of the
Russian Federation if you swing West in
your mental map of the Russian borders
he's kept moldova divided and frozen in
the Transnistria region divided since
the late 1990s he would into Crimea in
March 2014 and did what no European
leader had done since the Second World
War he not only occupied Crimea he
annexed it by an act of the Russian Duma
he stole the land from the Ukrainian
sovereign government and his troops are
still in eastern Ukraine in fact in the
last three or four months his troops
have been inciting a greater level of
violence than we've seen in quite some
time in eastern Ukraine in the Donbass
and has kept that country divided and
he's trying to destabilize our NATO
allies Estonia Latvia and Lithuania up
just in the northern part of Europe just
to the west of the Narva River as
Russian neighbours
Estonians have one third excusing
one-quarter ethnic Russians in their
population Latvians one-third so on a
south north line
to the south and west of the Russian
Federation Putin is seeking strategic
depth he's seeking effective control
over the fate of peoples and governments
of Nations in the way the Stalin and the
czars did in the past this is a big set
of problems for the Europeans to
undertake at one moment and that's why
people are worried about Europe and
worried that the United States night
might not be providing the type of
leadership currently that we have
provided in the past Donald Trump said
just before his election four days said
it really didn't matter to him whether
the European Union succeeded or failed
that turned 70 years of Republican Party
policy on his head it contradicted every
Republican as well as Democratic
president since Harry Truman he of
course has denigrated NATO he admitted
in a press conference two or three weeks
ago I guess NATO's now no longer
obsolete but that's not exactly a
ringing endorsement of a NATO alliance
and it doesn't provide the kind of
visionary leadership that Eisenhower and
Kennedy and Reagan and George HW Bush
and George W Bush Bill Clinton Barack
Obama the Europeans look to us for
friendship and leadership and strength
when they're facing Putin and Briggs it
and right-wing populist and refugee
crises and we're not giving them much
help middle east we could I'm sure you
have courses at Yale that now probably
last years to try to get a sense of
what's happening but just a couple of a
couple of trend lines for us to note for
president Trump to have to struggle with
we're now six and a half years after the
start believe it or not of the Arab
Spring so in aptly named the Arab
revolutions the Arab uprisings and most
experts in the Middle East believe that
this is a revolutionary spiral of
violence and instability that is not
going to end soon
in fact a lot of people think we're
looking another 10 15 20 years of
turbulence not throughout the Arab world
but in many parts of the Arab world
there are 22 Arab states Israel Iran
Turkey they comprise the modern Middle
East of the 22 Arab states maybe Morocco
and Tunisia are better off because of
the Arab revolutions no one else Egypt
is in turmoil right wing government
restive population quite Islamist it's
not violent doesn't means violent
doesn't mean it's unworthy that people
who want more of Islam in their society
life and government and that country is
ready to fracture unfortunately again
four failed states Libya and North
Africa five tribes contesting for power
no central authority that can run the
country or police it Yemen victim of a
proxy war between the great Sunni power
Saudi Arabia the great Shia power Iran
fueled by lots of guns from the United
States tens of thousands of civilians
killed in that war and yet our press not
covering it our government not talking
about it
Iraq divided unfortunately
semi-permanently into three parts the
Shia dominated south of Baghdad and
Basra where Iran's the great power now
no longer the United States I say that
with a great deal of regret given the
reality of modern Iran the Kurds want to
head out the door autonomous they have
some oil but they know that if they go
for independence the Turks the Iranians
the Iraqis the Syrians will resist it
we're the largest ethnic groups in the
world without its own state and of
course unbar province still in part
controlled by the Islamic state has been
for the last three years and our special
forces fighting today in Mosul with the
Iraqi army in this huge military
operation that's been underway since
last October to try to kick and push the
Islamic state out of Mosul eventually we
want to push them on a rock on northern
Syria but they've already metastasize
they're already in the Horn of Africa
they're already aligned with Boko Haram
in Nigeria they're already in West
Africa as are many of the al Qaeda
splinter groups so think of these
problems in the Middle East and think of
the failed States and think of countries
being overcome by internal revolutions
and social schisms think of Iran trying
to punch a big hole into the Sunni world
and the Saudis and Emiratis trying to
resist them in this Shia Sunni sectarian
conflict and then think of the tragedy
of Syria I just want to leave you with a
data point on Syria before the war
started the revolution I should say in
Syria which was early summer of 2011 the
United Nations reported that the
population of Syria was twenty two point
four million people and today the United
Nations reports that at least 12 million
of those twenty 2.4 million people are
homeless 12 million people it is the
greatest tragedy humanitarian tragedy in
the world today it's the largest
humanitarian tragedy since World War two
there are 65 million people displaced
all around the world 12 million of them
more than half the population of Syria
are Syrians 7 million homeless inside
the country I hate the antiseptic UN
term for this they say there internally
displaced makes it sound like they've
gone off to some hotel someplace right
internt they've been moved no they've
been blasted out of their homes by the
Syrian Air Force dropping these
bunker-busting bombs on civilian
neighborhoods and in Lib province in the
north and Aleppo
they've been blasted out of their homes
by the Russian Air Force mercilessly
bombing them
carpet bombing them they're victims of
jabhat al-nusra al Qaeda group of a
hundred other Sunni rebel groups of
their own government of the Islamic
state they're just on the run they're in
refugee camps there on the road whole
family's on the move trying to survive
there are seven people inside 7 million
inside the
country five million outside the country
so major refugee establishments camps
people living in really difficult
conditions in Jordan in Iraq in Turkey
in Lebanon one of every two kids in
eleven these public schools or Syrian
refugee kids and then you have thousands
living in horrible conditions on the
Greek islands and they can't be moved
off lesbos because they can't get the
right kind of authorization to go to
Athens and then you've got more than a
million living million point-five living
in various countries of Western Europe
trying to assimilate trying to survive
in every refugee crisis since World War
two the United States always takes half
the refugees that the United Nations
seeks to take in during that current
campaign so in this crisis we should
have taken in several hundred thousand
Syrian refugees we're a strong country
we're a wealthy country we have the
church groups we have the civic groups
we have the refugee associations to take
in people and to have them become
business owners small business people
and to have them become eventually
productive members of our society you
know many people who've taken in from
Syria
12500 all by President Obama zero by
President Trump and President Trump has
said in the greatest humanitarian crisis
since 1945 we're shutting the doors
we're digging a big my words not his big
moat around the country and we're
pulling up the drawbridge --is and we're
building big walls he says not a single
refugee when he gave that speech in
Harrisburg last Saturday night
it was a vile speech racist in what he
said about refugees and immigrants and
you just think here's this great country
whether our president's been Republican
or Democrat since Harry Truman and
Franklin Roosevelt we've always taken in
refugees and suddenly we say no and
we've also half the number of immigrants
coming into the United States under
President Trump leadership just in the
last
cut in half the last three months you
know you travel around the world and you
meet Europeans overwhelmed but these
problems and especially meet Arabs and
the proverbial question now to Americans
as you travel is what happened to you
where are you we need some help and the
United States is literally not helping
so that's just a glimpse of some of the
challenges we face in the Middle East
and finally in Asia ambassador Steve
Bosworth this is very eminent American
ambassador he passed away in December
2015
unfortunately great friend of ours at
Harvard former dean at Tufts he'd been
ambassador to the Philippines South
Korea it was President Obama's North
Korean negotiator he came into my
classroom two and a half years ago and
he said to my students he said the most
daunting challenge the United States has
ever faced in our history and I stopped
it right there and said you mean going
back to 1775 he said yes I said you mean
including the revolution of civil war
and the second row is he said the most
daunting challenge will be for the young
people here your generation to do two
things find a way to be partners with
China and yet not to be dominated by
China and he then described for my class
really brilliantly the fact that in many
ways China is not our enemy China is our
partner whether we're trying to manage
the global economy whether we're trying
to attack climate change and do
something about it whether we're trying
to undercut the human trafficking rings
or the drug traffickers how can you be
successful in the modern world without
working with China given China's
enormous strength and power and yet he
said at the same time the United States
is the paramount we in Washington words
academic words predominant military
power in Asia and we have been since the
end of the Second World War September 45
he said China is going to push out and
challenge the American strategic
position in the next generation and boy
was he right about that because she's in
ping
has been pushing the PLA the Bluewater
Navy with their huge and impressive
ballistic missiles their new aircraft
carrier is pushing them out into the
South China Sea they're contesting the
sovereignty of five other countries and
bullying them and taking their territory
in the Spratlys and Paracel Islands
they've been trying to push the Japanese
out of the Senkaku Islands we know a lot
about to sankaku Islands the United
States Marines took them in February
March 1945 as we were approaching the
Japanese home islands we administered
them from 1945 to 72 we transferred them
to Japan Chinese say they're ours
President Obama had to go to Tokyo in
2014 to say the sink aku's fall under
the us-japan defense treaty we will
defend them if necessary the Chinese
backed off sink aku's you know what the
populations ikkaku Islands friend of
mine Taylor for a wolle political
scientists at MIT came and said
population to my class of his in Kaku
Islands 140 goats there are no human
beings on the Senkaku Islands some of
these islets can't even be seen at high
tide and yet the Japanese and the
Chinese two of the great military powers
in the world are contesting each other
on the water and on the air today this
week over the Senkaku Islands so
ambassador Bosworth challenge to my
class really got my attention and he
helped me to visualize the challenge for
the next for our kids our grandchildren
and that is it would be catastrophic to
go to war with China given the power
that both of us have in the nuclear WMD
age and yet the United States should
hold on to a strategic position because
we have allies Japan South Korea
Australia treaty allies the Philippines
in Thailand with new security partners
Vietnam Singapore Malaysia India big
security partner president one of
president george w bush's great
achievements was to make india a
strategic partner of the United States
that's going to be one of his great
achievements I think historians will say
50 years from now and yet well we
hold on that strategic position you have
to work with China on the other issues I
talked about so hot here's the question
have we ever had a relationship in
American history where our strongest
partner is our strongest competitor
that's a sophisticated that's a
difficult balancing act which requires
leadership that has historically minded
that is sophisticated that is nuanced
that has a great deal of credibility so
let me just finish if that's the agenda
if we have enormous strengths if the
United States is in a strong position if
those are the three big issues and it's
not to diminish Latin America it's not
to diminish Africa it's not to diminish
South Asia but the issues that could
kill us that really involve our vital
national interest economically
militarily are at a weakening Europe of
revolutionary violent Middle East and
this huge long-term historical challenge
of what to do with China if those are
the big challenges boy we better have
good leadership in Washington we better
have people like George HW Bush he's my
when I visualize an American president I
visualize him maybe because I was very
young I was in my early 30s when I went
to work for him but it was it was a fact
that he had the Second World War
experience he had just about every job
in our government in the national
security establishment minister to China
they called him Minister in those days
whose name an ambassador yet director of
the CIA ambassador to the UN member of
Congress chairman of the Republican
Party vice president for eight
consequential years you need people with
that depth experience gravitas plus he
was so his honesty and George W Bush
shares all these traits by the way
incredible person and Bill Clinton does
too and Barack Obama personal
credibility honesty want to do right by
the country that's what we need in
Washington and I don't want to be unfair
the Trump administration but they start
from a very awkward position in this
respect if you just
to say to Bush 41 this is the
least-experienced cabinet we've had in
memory I'm not an historian professor
cage is but if you think the president's
the very first president in American
history going all the way back to
Washington with no prior experience in
public life all of our presidents have
either been a politician a mayor a
governor or senator a military officer a
diplomat and president Trump's the first
president not to have that background
the Secretary of State's never been in
government Secretary of Treasury's never
been in government Secretary of Commerce
has never been in government most of the
secretaries some of the secretaries were
hired it looks like to dismantle the
departments to which they've been
assigned and I don't want to go
overboard here and can I you know I do
live in this very big blue bubble all
the People's Republic of Cambridge
Massachusetts I'm aware of that but
experience counts and I and to give
President Trump a break and maybe the we
should all be a little bit patient I'll
bet he's going to be a very different
president a year from now than he is
today because this is a tough job to
have this trillion dollar budget multi
trillion dollar budget three million
employees I've lost count of how many
people work for the US government the
military and the civilian combined 195
counterparts out there as heads of
government 280 embassies and consulates
big combatant commands around the world
a separation of powers he's dealing with
the press they have First Amendment
rights he's dealing with the judiciary
and the Congress you know he's run a
family office in two floors of a
building in New York so you got to give
him a little bit you have to have
sympathy for the much different job he's
ever had
he'll be a better president I'll bet a
year from now and hopefully we'll have
learned what it takes to be president in
the modern age because his performance
in the first hundred plus days doesn't
give you a lot of hope castigating the
press almost making the press the enemy
we haven't had a president since Richard
Nixon try that dishonouring the
Judiciary
challenging the rights of judges to rule
against him which is of course
antithetical to the very idea of a
constitution of our Constitution and our
government right and so you have to hope
that there's a learning curve here and
an adaptive personality we study
leadership at Yale and Harvard and other
universities adaptive people are smart
enough to know that they don't know
everything especially if they're in a
new position that they need to have a
wide circle of people around them not
just people who say they're great but
people who actually challenge them and
say well maybe that wasn't such a great
thing to tweet out at 7:00 a.m. and
that's the circle of people you need
around you so there's a great deal of an
experience let's hope that problem is
taken care of sorts a year from now
here's the other problem however this is
a very deeply divided administration we
all know this ideologically and there
are two big factions I've never met
Steve Manon but boy is he famous now or
in some circles infamous he represents I
would say a radical right sense of
government what the government should be
what the country should be it's
completely divergent to the Republican
Party of the last 60 or 70 years if you
begin to talk about America as white and
Christian when the reality is that were
multi-ethnic and multi-religious and
that's our crowning glory as a country
it's our greatest strength that we are
multi-ethnic that were Muslim and right
and Hindu and Jewish and Christian and
atheistic and non-believers but we're a
community that respects each other
pluralistic alee if that's who we are
the ban in vision of America can't be
right it drives wedges between our in
our community it divides people on color
and on religion and we've done too much
of that in American history and we
fought our greatest conflict our most
noble conflict to erase it the battle
against the
Confederacy the battle against to
preserve the Union the ban envision is
being resisted you see it in Rex
Childress and Jim mattis HR McMaster
maybe even and I don't even know him
36 year old Jared Kushner and Ivanka
Trump they seem to have being more
centrist Morris I hate to use the e word
establishment oriented but I love this
kind of establishment because I
recognize it as constructive that
government has a role in this picture if
you're an establishment Republican that
may be the size of government isn't what
the Democrats want not what Bernie
Sanders wants but it's a rational view
and it's generous and there's a positive
vision in there not just a negative
divisive vision so who's going to win
the war of the roses inside the Trump
White House the war for the president's
future for his strategy for his heart
and soul that will tell us a lot about
what happens and finally there's policy
and a thing called strategy and the
president said I have an America first
banner the banner I fly well who can
argue against America for especially at
Yale by the way no historical pun or jab
intended who can argue that of course
any responsible American public official
would always put his or her country
first our job is to protect this country
think of our country first think of our
position first of course we do that but
there's some fault lines here we're not
quite sure what America first means does
America first mean that we don't trade
with other countries that we dismantle
the multilateral trade system that
President Cedillo helped to nurture that
President George HW Bush helped to build
I happen to think that NAFTA is one of
the great success stories of the United
States over the last 30 or 40 or 50
years and President Trump now may be
wholly modernize it in the upcoming
negotiations but he had been threatening
to
Radek ated I thought that President
Obama's positioning of the United States
in the trans-pacific partnership 40% of
global GDP was that we would write the
rules of trade for the next generation
we the law-abiding free trade countries
of the world so that China which doesn't
play by the rules in India which is
highly protectionist would have to
adhere to the trans-pacific partnership
countries Mexico Canada the United
States three of them
president Trump renounced that on his
first day of office renounced the US EU
trade agreement so does America first
mean that were kind of 18th century
Americans we don't really want to trade
we want it what we've always traded but
want to protect raise high walls build
walls which i think is the ugliest thing
one can do george HW bush helped to
bring a wall down in berlin president
trumps going to raise an ugly divisive
wall with our great friend mexico so
what will America first mean on trade
what will it mean on immigration and
refugees we've talked about that do we
close our doors to our history and what
does it mean about our alliances if
there's a power difference between
Russia and United States and between the
United States and China is that they
have no allies and we have lots of
allies who will fight for us on 9/11
when I was representing President George
W Bush I was the American ambassador of
NATO and when we were hit and those
3,000 people died in New York and
Washington when the Pentagon was burning
and the Twin Towers had come down
everybody in this room remembers that
day bitterly well maybe with the
exception of some of the younger
students and the second and third rows I
was the American ambassador of NATO in
the State Department and White House and
Pentagon had been evacuated we couldn't
reach anybody by phone for four or five
hours and the Canadian ambassador David
Reich came to me and said have we
thought about invoking article 5 of a
NATO treaty article 5 is the famous
clause that says an attack on one of us
is an attack on all of us the Europeans
insisted that Acheson and Marshall and
Truman agree to that because they fully
expected
to attack and for the Americans and
Canadians to have to come across the
pond a third time and the huge
historical irony is the only time we
ever invoked it was the next day
September 12 2001 it was the Europeans
coming to our rescue and I must say it
was incredibly emotional to sit there on
behalf of our government and to hear
country after country say we will go to
war with you and they all went into
Afghanistan and they've all bled in
Afghanistan and they're all still there
so when I hear our president denigrate
NATO and say that we don't really need
these countries and what do they do for
us they're all still fighting for us
and with us in Afghanistan today whereas
our historical memory so that's the
third big issue for me after trade and
immigrants and refugees and alliances as
America first mean America only and does
that make any sense at all in the era of
globalization if that's the name of the
era in which we live that our faith is
linked with everybody else in the world
that we cannot escape the rest of the
world that we have to be in the world
not just looking at it from afar does
America first work and to take this a
little bit further Yale graduate David
Brooks I don't always agree with Yale
graduate David Brooks who writes the
column the New York Times but I always
read his column because he's a very
smart person he's an intellectual
he believes in ideas and he challenges
us he's written two things in the last
few months that really had interested me
he said are we witnessing first he said
on the attack on reason the attack on
facts the attack on empirical thought
are we witnessing a big change in
America against our enlightenment values
he said the framers of our Constitution
were children of the Enlightenment think
of Madison and Hamilton and Jefferson
and John Jay they were enlightened
figures they believed in reason in
science not just myth are we going back
to renounce enlightenment values Daniel
Patrick Moynihan said famously you're
entitled to your own opinion but
not entitled to your own facts and David
Brooks is worrying that this big
movement in Washington this populist
movement is meant to take away science
and empiricism and reason in fact and
the second thing he said more recently
is who's going to stand up for the West
well I've been describing in this talk
which is coming by the way mercifully to
an end in just a minute is a liberal
world order what we call it in academia
but it's the world that Roosevelt
envisioned that Truman and Eisenhower
and all their descendants built and
we've succeeded in building a world that
honors democracy and human freedom and
free trade and relative borders they're
not wide open but open enough that
people can walk back and forth say
across the us-mexican border as they do
to the benefit of both countries who's
going to defend that world and do we now
have the very first American president
in our memory in a century who doesn't
believe in that world who believes in a
meaner more insular isolated American
first strategy I'm worried I worry every
day about this but then I think about
the press writing courageously to
question the president and all of us and
the courts acting independently and your
vision is restored your faith is
restored in this great country of ours
as we soldier on thank you very much
so happy to talk about any of these
issues or any issues that I left out
please disagree I always tell my
students disagree constructive critisism
good tell me where I'm wrong yes sir I
have a very brief comment and perhaps a
simplistic question my comment is I
think to speculate that Trump is going
ever going to stop blaming the media is
at best a pipe dream my question
involves your speculation that America
will be a leader in the world for the
next three or four decades and it's
based on the following I think at Yale
and Harvard there are there are perhaps
not probably not a majority but there is
a great percentage of students who are
not American citizens and the number of
non Americans applying to institutions
like these has drastically dropped
because of Trump's policies on 60
minutes this week there was an expose on
a guy who made millions on Wall Street
and went over to Somaliland and
established two school where nobody
speaks English and he has just graduated
his first students who were able to come
to great American universities like
Oberlin Yale one one girl here is here
at Yale and there was a throwaway line
at the end of the piece which basically
I didn't hear it well but I think they
said they will no longer be able to
attend colleges in the US so my
simplistic question is you know we also
hear things like people like the
ancestors of Trump and Albert Einstein
would not be able to come to this
country if Trump's policies were in
place at the time so my question is do
you think you know I'm involved in
education and I know that American
education through through high school is
rather inferior to the rest of the world
do you think this all of this is going
to contribute to a decline in America
snatcher it's a very thoughtful question
it's a very and first well I agree with
your comment I think the president is he
thinks he's succeeding by making the
press and the enemy and his whole speech
and Harris burgers against the press
immigrants and refugees so I expect him
to continue that I agree with you
second on your question and harder we
have I think about 10% of our students
are from another country or they may be
maybe a dual national citizen from the
United States in the in the in Harper
college undergraduate the Kennedy School
by design we're about half international
by design we want to be half
international of our thousand students
in our graduate school and I can tell
you when the first Immigration and
Refugee banned the [ __ ] ban because it
was a Muslim ban was put forward a lot
of our students in the Muslim world did
not go home on spring break we have this
tradition at the Kennedy School where
our students organize themselves and
they go off by the hundreds to North
Korea
Darfur they go all over the world
together to study and a lot of our
Muslim students didn't go because they
didn't know if they get back in through
Logan Airport where they'd be admitted
or not and that really was a terrible
thing for those kids those young people
to have to think that they were stranded
here and oh you know I haven't I haven't
looked at our admissions data for the
next year the only we've just we've just
admitted lots of people both of our
institutions but anecdotally you do hear
that admissions applications excuse me
at Oxford Cambridge are up at Sheila's
PO in Paris because a lot of kids from
the Middle East just don't feel that
they're welcome United States how sad is
that how sad is that that our country
would send that signal so it's a very
thoughtful question we got to be attuned
to these issues on University campuses
and protect our students you know I'm a
ghost
I'm not a political scientist I study
the rest of the world more than my own
country I just have this faith that his
view of America is not the predominant
view in this country
and I suppose a sensible Republican or a
sensible Democrat will replace him in
2020 he won't win reelection if he tries
that's my faith but I might I might be
wrong about that I could very well be
wrong about that
presents a deal we are very happy that
you are here and also a little bit
jealous of Harvard or having you there I
got here well I hope you are right mr.
ambassador that in one year time and
President Trump will be a totally
different leader that he is today but
that's what the good of the United
States and for the good of the rest of
the world we we hope you're right and we
have over so far the evidence of that
transformation decidable transformation
is rather mix it is true that some
high-level officials in the Trump
administration go to places like the
Munich Security Conference I don't know
whether you were there this year I went
there too and you and your hair the Vice
President and you heard a Secretary of
Defense mattis saying exactly the
opposite of what President Trump had
said in the previous day's and weeks
well that's evidence that some things
can change I think so far we cannot
really be convinced at least from
outside that we will see a very
different leader president here so the
question is whether and those checks and
balances to which you also made
reference starting with the press which
i think is playing a fantastic role
positively will really be sufficient to
prevent a terrible disaster for this
country for other countries thank you
very much and you know I didn't mean to
suggest naively that there'll be a
President Trump will be a very different
person a year from now with completely
different views but I think at least the
administration will have more experience
interest in getting the government to
function because right now the cabinet
officers don't appear to be plugged into
the civil and the civil service I was in
Washington yesterday and I can tell you
at least in my old agency my home agency
the State Department and I have great
respect for secretary Tillis and he's a
very fine person but he's he's
surrounded by just a couple of people up
on the seventh floor in the State
Department in the Foreign Service my
brethren don't feel included and they're
looking at 30% budget cuts to our
diplomacy in USAID that would devastate
our ability there are four famines in
the world today there are these public
health crises malaria right HIV how are
we going to respond to these how we
going to respond to the war and peace'
situations without our diplomats so
that's a big challenge I would say the
answer to your question really is I'm
sorry to say the Democratic Party is
marginal right now in terms of its real
influence there are blocking force as we
saw in health care and we'll see it in
lots of other issues but they can't
really promote ideas the battles in the
Republican Party it's fascinating to
watch on the issues that I talked about
of foreign policy and national security
there's been a big push back against
President Trump by John McCain Lindsey
Graham Marco Rubio Susan Collins remain
it's really interesting to see Mitch
McConnell and Paul Ryan had profound
disagreements with President Trump that
they have expressed on Russia and on
NATO in two quick vignettes I've
testified twice before Congress in the
last five weeks first time was in the
state aid budget House Foreign Affairs
Committee 45 members is a huge committee
I went in saying don't cut the State
Department ID build them up I thought
all the Republicans would disagree every
single Republican agreed with me with
one exception Dana Rohrabacher who is a
very conservative member from Orange
County but ed Royce the Chairman
Republican conservative they all took
the position that
thirty percent budget cuts to our
diplomats and aid workers is insane
those are the words they used and then
last week I testified before the Senate
Banking Committee Republicans shared
obviously they have the majority and the
issue was should we sanction Russia over
its interference in our election in 2000
in the autumn I took the position that
the Russians interfered grotesquely they
very likely interfered on behalf of
President Trump against Secretary
Clinton
that's not my judgment that's the FBI
and intelligence community judgment in
their January 7th report to the American
people I took the position we should
have new tough sanctions
not a single person disagreed with that
view all the Republicans agreed and yet
President Trump has not launched an
investigation of its own
he has denigrated the Congressional need
for a congressional investigation he's
never once criticized Putin for
intervening in our election and the
Republicans are against him so what
gives me a little bit of hope as a
citizen is that the push backs coming
from the Republican Party are not all
the issues unfortunately not on health
care I'm a believer in Obama care I
wanted to send Obama care I wanted to
offend our climate position we're going
to lose on some issues but not on every
issue so that's the space that's
interesting to watch in Washington the
intra Republican battle for the future
of the Republican Party the soul of that
party in a lot of ways um
yes sir oh you've got the mic right yes
thank you yeah yeah I think I think it's
not oh yeah yeah thank you um anyway so
you started off your talk talking about
the see the very secure position in
America is and right now and I would
agree with that but because America is
such a secure position do you think that
that we can then afford a draw some
drawdown in our military forces abroad
and if so would you actually tell Trump
to decrease military spending instead of
trying to Ratchet it up as he's doing
thank you very much good question
anybody hear the question can we afford
to draw down militarily well maybe I
miss
probably miscommunicated I think you
know we're far the strongest country but
if I think of the threat of that the
Islamic state poses to the Arab world
and the African countries of Central and
West Africa we need our military to be
involved not with a hundred thousand
troops there in these places but from
the air Special Forces training if I
think of the problem on the Korean
Peninsula with Kim Jong on probably
getting a nuclear weapon in the next
three to five years that can hit
California Oregon Washington in the
Rocky Mountain States and then think
about the fact that Russia is back
dividing Europe and we need to contain
Russian power with a stronger armored
American Force land force in Europe as
well as air force I actually support the
increases in the defense budget I'm not
sure I support the totality but
president Trump wants to do which is a
huge increase by historical standards
but I wouldn't cut the military budget
and I guess I'd say second finally that
strong American strategic position that
I described and I believe in it can be
wasted away in a generation if we don't
have a proper leadership if we're not
credible because the words of our
president can't be taken as truthful and
that's a problem three days ago
four days ago the president said we're
going to have perhaps a major major
crisis with North Korea and then
yesterday he said his words I'd be
honored to meet Kim jong-un if you flip
so wildly from one pole to another in
three or four days who's going to take
you seriously it was the Wall Street
Journal not The New York Times about
three or four weeks ago that ran an
editorial on this saying our is the
credibility of the president so reduced
president Trump that when we do have a
genuine crisis crisis with North Korea
will anybody even believe us because
he's the boy who cried wolf
he's on all sides of all issues and you
have to believe in something and stick
to it one things I admired about
president george w bush i think he gets
too much criticism he had a core set of
beliefs
you knew exactly what they were all of
our adversaries knew what they were they
knew that what he said was going to be
what we did and you don't know that now
and that's dangerous for the United
States so you know I'm describing a
position that all these great presidents
have built up for us and I don't want to
see it wasted away by the time my
granddaughter graduates from Yale or
some other institution 17 years from now
you know you don't want that to happen
to our next generation you need a
commander-in-chief a president who is a
trustworthy sincere honest individual
and I'm sorry to sound like a broken
record but from the ethics problems of
not releasing taxes and making 20-odd
trips to his own properties as president
to play golf thereby Crossing ethical
lines left and right by this illusive
attachment to truth in all the missed
statements which is a nice word by the
way a nice diplomatic word I didn't say
I didn't use the l word we need leaders
who can be believed by them by the
American people in the rest of the world
and we're not in that territory right
now so that that's what I worry about
it's the leadership part of it that I
worry about all the way in the back yes
please um it was working yes it is yes
okay great um thank you so much for
coming um last year I believe it was
last year but um you co-authored an
article in The Washington Post about the
where you recommended Obama to
reconsider the idea of a safe zone in
Syria yes could you elaborate more on
why you think this is if you still
believe this is a wise path to go on to
and if so what are the main challenges
faced by the Trump administration to
establish such a safe zone thank you
yeah I did write an article in The
Washington Post with my friend
ambassador Jim Jeffrey who is president
george w bush's deputy national security
adviser and ambassador to iraq for
president obama another career diplomat
and we said given the 12 million
homeless given the fact that Syria has
been blown
part as a nation-state our argument was
well first President Obama should have
should have used force in September 2013
when President Assad used chemical
weapons and I actually supported
President Trump by the way a month ago
when he use force but argument was we
had to do something on a humanitarian
basis to help the refugees that one
thing we could do and be very tough
would be to carve out safe zones on the
turkish-syrian border and the Syrian and
Jordanian border with the Arabs with
Sunni Arab militia with some of the Arab
states and with Turkey and protect those
safe zones on the ground with troops and
cover them by air cover to keep the
Russians and Syrians out there'd be
places big places 2030 miles across in
that scarred landscape where the
refugees could go and not have to be
bombed it could establish refugee camps
we acknowledged this being
extraordinarily difficult in wartime
that you'd have to assume casualties
that we would have to be part of this to
give it legitimacy and credibility the
major work would have to be done by the
Sunni Arabs on the ground and it was
interesting that two people came out not
just to support us because that we're
not lonely voices out there a lot of
people have said this Hillary Clinton
during the campaign check out her
website said we should be and we should
be building safe havens to protect
people and you know who else did Donald
Trump three or four weeks ago was
president he kind of mused shouldn't we
be helping these people I might look
into safe havens and we didn't hear
anything about it we probably won't but
I was encouraged that President Trump
said that and I agreed with him and I
think that people like me have been
critics when we agree with President
Trump we should say that when I came out
in support of his airstrikes against
Syria I took it from some members of my
family we're very upset with me how can
you favor President Trump well you have
to if you've been arguing one position
and then the government does something
that is compatible with it you've got to
support the president so I was
encouraged that President Trump said
that and I still think we have to do
something to help
Ariane's it's a humanitarian imperative
it's a moral imperative it's also a
national security imperative I think yes
sir please and we have a mic coming
right down the row here I think they
want you to use that okay thanks
I'm going to cheat by asking a quick
follow-up and then my my larger question
the the key question is on North Korea
what is it that Kim Jong reasonably
wants or what can we reasonably give to
him and I use the term giving quotes to
calm that situation down so that it
doesn't negatively lead to some kind of
larger conflict
so that's follow up to a your discussion
at Korea and then the other thing is I
my beautiful wife to my left is from
Venezuela we were married in Venezuela
and I just curious to get your take on
that unfolding situation down there and
whether you have any predictions as to
how that may ultimately play out and
resolve it so thank you very much thank
you on North Korea board we could have a
whole course at Yale on North Korea
maybe there is you know it seems like
this is the way I described this to my
students is a little cheeky but I think
it's true think of Tony Soprano remember
Tony Soprano think of a Mafia family and
the real goal is survive and just hold
your position on the street you know in
the market whatever market he was in
drugs and this is a mafia family Kim Il
Sung Kim jong-il Kim Jong on that's 70
years of North Korean history it's a
family-run dictatorship when someone
gets too close to the throne even if
they're your uncle or nephew you kill
them which is what Kim jong-un has been
doing pretty regularly over the last
couple of years so what's the goal
someone like that survival of his puppet
kingdom of his authoritarian rule
survival it's there's famine poorest
country on earth
lise industrialized country on earth
hasn't done a thing for his people
survival of his family dictatorship
someone who he favors I don't know how
many kids he has one of those kids is
going to be the ones if he survives that
he promotes
and I actually think there is not a
military solution here because we know
he has nuclear weapons and we know he
has mobile road launchers so he can
transport they're not stationary nuclear
weapons he can hide them and you don't
want to play Russian roulette with him
you don't want mean some people would
say well why don't we just go in there
with conventional weapons and knock out
his nuclear whiffle's well the only
problem with that is a do you know how
many he has and B once you strike if you
don't get all of them then he can hit
back with a nuclear weapon and then
you've started a nuclear war and there's
10 million people living in Seoul which
is for all of you been to South Korea
3040 miles below the Demilitarized Zone
is this great modern city with 10
million people in it and 25,000 American
troops in the most heavily mined part of
the world between the DMZ and Seoul it'd
be catastrophic to launch a war so
that's number one number two President
Trump I think it's done the right thing
here I've also been supporting in my
North Korea because I think he's trying
to leverage the Chinese and say to the
Chinese you got to be part of this
solution here and if you really want to
be a global power prove it that's what
President Obama said do it
the Chinese that's what President George
W Bush did we've been disappointed by
the Chinese because while they're
frustrated by the North Koreans they
don't like Kim Jong on he's never been
to Beijing
they don't under him they prefer the
division of Korea the Chinese to the
unification of the Korean Peninsula with
a democratic country based in Seoul
capital Seoul aligned with us the
Chinese hate that scenario versus the
status quo so I think the president what
my one argument with President Trump
would be don't oversell the Chinese
publicly you know the last couple weeks
the president's been like courting Xi
Jinping publicly saying very nice things
which is good but I think if you tell
the American people China's going to
solve it they won't so where's that
leave us we're going to have to
negotiate and yet Sakura bean did say to
justify his negotiations with our fought
you don't negotiate with your best
friends who negotiate and the words of
Rabine with very unsafe
every enemies and the only way forward
that I can figure out I think this was
where the Trump administration is
heading but they don't want to say it
and I understand that they want to
negotiate that's why President Trump
said I be honored to meet him why Sean
Spicer made the terrible mistake of
trying to humanize Kim Jung and to
briefing yesterday well he's a smart
cookie you know he's really he's a young
man and he's built up his country I
think we're getting ready to negotiate
now will Kim jong-un agree to destroy
his nuclear weapons no because then he'd
sign away his future then he wouldn't
survive so maybe the best we can do is
freeze their nuclear weapons program in
place and then understand that at some
point when that agreements being
implemented North Korea will cheat
because that's what they did to
President Clinton and that's related to
President George W Bush when I work for
him we enter into these agreements in
good faith and the North Koreans cheated
on both but it buys you some time so
people say why would you do that why
would you negotiate this half-hearted
compromise because the best we can do
because it makes the situation a little
less dangerous than it is today and in
the messy world of international
politics where you can't get everything
you want it's the best we can do and
maybe Trump's the guy to do it's like
Nixon to China you know a strong anti
Chinese leader like Richard Nixon as
president knows very well was the guy
who could do this to mess and survive
domestically maybe Trump because he's
tough guy because he's you know strong
leader maybe he can say I've got to do
this I can't resolve the problem but I'm
a good negotiator I'll make it a little
less dangerous for us and you know what
I'd support him I hope that's where
they're going I think that is where
they're going it's a great question we
could talk about this for hours
Venezuela it's a tragedy to see the
economy implode so many people suffer
and this dictator left-wing dictator
Nicolas Maduro tyrannize terrorize the
Venezuelan people in the opposition
movement
and you just have to hope that Venezuela
you know doesn't descend into energy or
a civil war and I guess if I gave you a
headline on Latin America I'd say maybe
the most one of the most hopeful places
in the world right now and the Americas
we couldn't have a better country of
neighbor I mean that sincerely the neck
Mexico in Canada you have this great
democratic capitalist revolution in Peru
and Chile Colombia has been relieved
from its civil war the FARC has been
being reintroduced into society if
Brazil if if Brazil could straighten
itself out politically and economically
this could be a great era in the
Americas but I look around the world and
I think the maybe the two most hopeful
areas are sub-saharan Africa we're
seeing big GDP growth rates in
sub-saharan Africa Chinese are building
lots of infrastructure that's good not
bad it's good in many ways we're seeing
HIV rates fall because of President
Bush's PEPFAR program George W Bush 30
billion dollars it's probably the thing
he now is most celebrated for he was
just there he and Laura Bush in
sub-saharan Africa they are lionized the
bushes in southern Africa because of
PEPFAR this is the president's emergency
program against a for AIDS relief and so
all the dark story I gave you about
Europe and the Middle East and Asia I
think there's a brighter story to be
told with some exceptions Venezuela
being one in Latin America and Africa
professor how many questions you want me
to take I'm happy to stay as long as you
want we have one time for one more okay
um who would yes sir
from a reaction to 9/11 and at the end
you were admiring the way NATO Kings oh
arcade right after 9/11 and once
Afghanistan what what is it 11 long um I
think we were right to go into
Afghanistan we were hit from Afghanistan
that's where Al Qaeda was its sanctuary
and so we had every right to go in it's
been an enormous ly difficult mission
we're in year 16 we're going to have to
stay many more years with low levels of
troops but money to help support the
Afghans I think in retrospect we came
out punching after 9/11 maybe you know
it was understandable the psychological
shock in retrospect I think that going
into Iraq in March 2003 was a great
mistake I have to share in that mistake
I was in the government ambassador NATO
I supported the war and so I am I have
to share responsibility for that we sent
a lot of soldiers from NATO countries to
Iraq as well as to Afghanistan I think
it was a mistake I think some of what
our military did are I should say our
defense establishment really wasn't the
uniform military as much as ordered this
but Guantanamo was a mistake it became a
symbolic albatross the United States I
think that's the way that President Bush
and Secretary Rice thought at the end of
the Bush administration certainly
President Obama did I don't know why
president Trump internal sessions want
to keep the quantou Nomo open it doesn't
work for us it's a negative symbol of
America and certainly Abu Ghraib and
torture were wrong and John McCain stood
up against torture President Bush stood
up against torture and Secretary Rice
did in the second term as you know but
in the first term there were abuses that
were contrary to America's traditions
and that dishonored us and that we need
to account for but I was part of those
administration so I'm not trying to I'm
not trying to escape responsibility for
that you you know you can see so much
more clearly we look into the past with
20/20 vision not to excuse it but we
have to learn from these lessons Bob
Gates when he left a Secretary of
Defense boy what a smart guy
in 2011 said the next reflecting on your
question the next American president
excuse me the next American Secretary of
Defense who advises an American
President to send a big American land
army into Asia to occupy an Arab or
Asian country ought to have his or her
head examined and may we always remember
this and I think again I mean I've said
a lot of harsh things about President
Trump and I meant every one of them but
I think where he captured some of the
public sentiment during the campaign was
no more big foreign Wars of that type we
didn't have to fight either of them they
were Wars of choice
they weren't Wars of necessity like the
Second World War or even the Gulf War of
1990 and 91 was I think a war of
necessity and we and we have to be very
leery of those kind of entanglements big
armies to occupy other countries is one
thing to liberate when you try to occupy
people don't like it even when you've
liberated them they quickly they turn it
they turned on us in three or four weeks
and we should have expected it we didn't
see it coming we didn't anticipate the
problems of the occupation I actually
teach a case study of this at Harvard
and very self-critical of my involvement
others that we just didn't see clearly
we thought we were going in to liberate
Baghdad we didn't know we were going to
buy it and owned it for eight years we
should have so I'm humble about this you
know we made a lot of mistakes but we're
still a great country I still rather
have us be the top country not Russia or
China and I certainly don't want to
diminish all the good things the
president george w bush did and he's an
honorable person and i think i think
that all parts of his record should come
out not just the iraq part big part of
it but did a lot of good things too so
thank you very much for listening to me
it's been a pleasure to be at yale thank
you
you
[Music]